Mein Name ist Ucak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Edwin Rothardt.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchtebieren?
Ja. R-O-T-H-A-R-D. Meine Nachname, mein Vorname, E-D-W-I-N. Edwin.
Wie soll ich Sie ansprechen?
Herr Rothardt.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
2. Mai 1977.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit, Herr Rothardt?
70 Kilogramm.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen.
Herr Rothardt, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zurzeit?
Ja, Doktor. Ich fühle mich ständig müde und antreiblos. Ich bin total erschöpft, Doktor.
Herr Rothardt, seit wann leiden Sie unter diesen Beschwerden?
Ich habe diese Beschwerden seit drei Monaten.
Sind diese Beschwerden langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Diese Beschwerden treten langsam aus, ja.
Okay. Also ich meine, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Herr Rothardt, zum Beispiel, haben Sie einen Anhörigen verloren oder haben Sie Ihre Arbeit verloren?
Ja, Doktor. Vor vier Jahren bin ich getrennt.
Ich habe drei Kinder, nein, vier Kinder.
Zwei sind meine Ex-Frau und zwei sind meine neue Freundin.
Es gibt viele Probleme und ich habe Stress über Arbeit. Ich arbeite als Pfleger.
Okay. Sind Ihre Kinder gesund, Herr Rothardt?
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, meine Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Okay, das freut mich. Haben sich Ihre Beschwerden mit der Zeit verändert?
Also ich meine, sind die Beschwerden schlimmer geworden oder besser geworden?
Diese Beschwerden sind in der Zeit schlimmer geworden, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Rothardt?
Ich habe keine Lust, etwas zu machen. Zum Beispiel, ich möchte nicht mit meinen Freunden treffen oder etwas Gutes machen.
Außerdem habe ich in den letzten drei Monaten etwa vier Kilo abgenommen.
Ohne dass ich es wollte. Außerdem habe ich kaum Appetit.
Ich verstehe. Herr Rothardt, fühlen Sie sich wertlos?
Wertlos? Ich verstehe nicht. Was ist wertlos?
Wertlosigkeit. Ich bin kein Wert. Ich bin nicht mehr wert.
Ich möchte nicht mehr.
Ja, Sie haben Recht. Ich habe.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, haben Sie?
Außerdem möchte ich nicht auf den Bett kommen.
Also Sie leiden unter Schlepplichkeit?
Ja, ich möchte ganz Tag schlafen.
Tagsüber, okay. Alles klar.
Und haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich habe keine Schlafstörungen. Ich möchte immer schlafen, Doktor.
Ich möchte nicht aufwachen.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Seit wann?
Seit sehr lange, ungefähr ein Jahr.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ich habe bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 15 mg eingenommen.
500 mg meint er?
Aber das ist nicht Verbesserung gebracht.
Leiden Sie unter diesen Kopfschmerzen dauerhaft?
Nein, fern vor mir.
Okay. Wie sind diese Schmerzen am Kopf?
Mein Zittern und Hinterkopf. Manchmal ganz Kopf. Ich bin nicht sicher.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, ich...
Ich habe verschiedene Bereiche Kopfschmerzen.
Alles klar. Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie besonders an chronischen Erkrankungen leiden.
Wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit, Schilddrüsenprobleme.
Ja. Ich habe seit sechs Jahren eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme L-Troxine.
Okay. Und besuchen Sie Ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig?
Ja. Ich gehe mindestens zwei Monate bei meinem Hausarzt.
Okay. Wann wurden Ihre letzten Schilddrüsenwerte kontrolliert?
Vor zwei Monaten?
Vor zwei Monaten.
War alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja. Alles in Ordnung.
Okay. Kennen Sie die Dosierung von L-Troxine?
Ich verstehe nicht. Ich kenne nicht den Doktor.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie dieses Medikament regelmäßig ein?
Ja, ja. Am Abend. Entschuldigung. Morgens.
Morgens. Okay. Alles klar.
Herr Rothardt, leiden Sie unter Heißigkeit?
Ich fühle mich nicht heiß, Doktor. Nein.
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Heißigkeit?
Ja, ja. Ich verstehe. Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Hautveränderung bemerkt?
Zum Beispiel trockene Haut oder trockene Haare?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt. Nein. Ich habe nicht diese Bewertung. Ja.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Vergrößerung am Hals bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Spüren Sie, dass Ihr Herz langsam erschlägt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Nein.
Okay. Haben Sie Konzentrationsstörungen, Herr Rothardt?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Manchmal habe ich diese Beschwerden. Ja.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Verstopfung?
Verstopfung bei mir nicht aufgefallen. Nein.
Okay. Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe keine dieser Beschwerden.
Okay. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, ja. Alles ist in Ordnung, ja.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor.
Okay. Leiden Sie Husten oder Luftnot?
Bei mir sind diese Beschwerden nicht aufgefallen, Doktor. Nein.
Okay. Alles klar.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein. Das freut mich.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Schildtrüchen unter Funktion leiden und auch Sie haben eine chronische Kopfschmerzen.
Ja. Sonst noch etwas? Haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe keine anderen wichtigen Erkrankungen, Doktor.
Okay. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf irgendwelche anderen Medikamente, außer genannten?
Ich habe keine anderen Medikamente. Ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Okay. Super. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ich hatte keine Operation, Doktor. Nein.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen, Nahrungsmittel?
Ja. Ich reagiere allergisch auf Pollen.
Und wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Die äußern sich bei mir mit Blähungen und Verdankstörungen.
Das ist eine Pollenallergie? Ja.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas?
Das war es. Okay. Herr Rothardt, rauchen Sie?
Ja. Ich rauche nicht, Doktor.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Ich habe nicht geraucht.
Das freut mich. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja. Ich trinke hauptsächlich Wein.
Letzter Zeit wurde es aber mehr.
Zwei bis drei Gläser täglich.
Also wegen dieser Beschwerden, oder?
Ja, wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe keine Lust.
Und ich trinke leider viel Alkohol.
Herr Rothardt, nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich kontakte nicht Drogen. Nein.
Okay, das freut mich.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte,
wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall, Bluthochdruck?
Meine Mutter hatte Brustkrebs.
Lebt Ihre Mutter noch?
Ja, meine Mutter und mein Vater leben jetzt.
Okay.
Mein Vater hat Durchblutungsstörungen.
Meinen Sie an den Beinen, oder?
In den Unterschenkeln, ja.
Okay. Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ich habe einen Bruder, Entschuldigung.
Ist er gesund?
Nein, Bruder ist nach einem Unfall gelähmt.
Okay, alles klar. Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Herr Rothardt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie getrennt sind.
Und Sie leben mit Ihren Freunden.
Ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Rothardt, ich möchte einige Fragen über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden stellen.
Also, haben Sie Selbstmordgedanken? Darf ich fragen?
Selbst?
Selbstmordgedanken?
Nein.
Das freut mich.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, waren Sie, also sind Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden schon beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich bin nicht beim anderen Arzt gewesen.
Und haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen, pflanzliche Mittel oder andere Medikamente?
Haben Sie probiert?
Nein, ich habe nicht probiert, ja.
Okay.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, haben Sie Empfindlichkeit gegen besonders Kälte oder Wärme bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay. Herr Rothardt, das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, was habe ich? Ich habe gesagt, ich habe Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Diese Beschwerden dagegen, diese Krankheit oder?
Also, Herr Rothardt, es ist zu früh etwas genau zu sagen, aber diese Beschwerden können mit der Schilddrüsenunterfunktion verbunden sein, ja.
Aber zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen, dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sie haben jetzt einige depressive Verstimmung.
Wie gesagt, Schilddrüsenunterfunktion kann diese Probleme verursachen.
Und wie gesagt, ich werde diese Probleme zuerst kontrollieren.
Dann, sobald die Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich mit Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen, okay?
Ja, Doktor, danke schön. Ich brauche Ihre Hilfe, ja. Ich habe keine Lust um mein Leben, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Herr Rothardt. Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus und in guten Händen bei uns. Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen, okay?
Okay.
Okay, warten Sie bitte im Wartezimmer, nehmen Sie einen Platz. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay, danke schön, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Abend, Herr Oberarzt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Edwin Rothardt ist 48 Jahre alt, 1,78 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Rothardt starrte sich bei uns wegen seit drei Monaten bestehender chronischer Fatigue, Aszenie und depressiver Verstimmung vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Beschwerden langsam aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Er berichtete über Lustlosigkeit, Friedenlosigkeit, Inappetenz und Gewichtsabnahme von 4 Kilogramm innerhalb von vier Monaten.
Außerdem klagte er über Wertlosigkeit und Somnolenz tagsüber.
Die Fragen nach Dysphonie, Schlafstörungen in der Nacht, trockene Haut, trockene Haare, Halsvergrößerung, Bradycardie, Obstipation, Selbstmordgedanken, Kälteintoleranz wurden verneint.
Der Patient klagte über auch Konzentrationsstörungen. Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig und er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit einem Jahr bestehenden Cephalgie und seit sechs Jahren bestehende Hypotheriose.
Die Cephalgie tritt an den Stirn und den Hinterkopf auf.
Der Patient nehme dagegen Ibuprofen 500mg bei Bedarf ein. Der Patient nehme gegen Hypotheriose L-Tiroxin morgens ein und die Dosierung sollte geklärt werden.
Der Patient besucht seinen Hausarzt alle zwei Monate regelmäßig. Er sei bisher noch nie operiert worden und er habe Allergie gegen Pollen, die sich durch Meteorismus und Verdauungsstörungen äußert.
Mikrotinkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint und er trinke zwei bis drei Gläser Wein täglich wegen dieser aktuellen Beschwerden.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass die Mutter an Mammakarzinom leide und der Vater leide an Pavk.
Er hatte einen Unfall und leide an Lehmung.
Er sei getrennt seit vier Jahren, lebe mit seiner Freundin und er habe vier Kinder und die Kinder sind gesund.
Er lebe mit zwei Kindern zusammen, andere zwei Kinder leben mit ihrer Mutter. Er sei Pfleger von Beruf und habe viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Hypothriose aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter Gewichtsabnahme, Inapetens, chronischer Fatigue, Asthenie, Wertlosigkeit, Somnolens, tagsüber.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Hypothriose, als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Depression und Anämie in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei den Patienten zunächst die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, also Palo, getrockener Haut, trockener Haare, Nagelveränderungen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild CAP, BSG, TSH, Freit 3, Freit 4, TPO, TR und TG Antikörper, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Thyroid-Synchrographie durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Thyroid-Syntagraphie durchführen, um die kalten Knoten oder heißen Knoten genau zu beurteilen.
Und gegebenenfalls würde ich eine Fein-Nadel-Biopsie durchführen, um eine Thyroid-Kalzinome auszuschließen.
Und ich würde ein endokrinologisches Konsil und ein psychologisches Konsil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientestation aufnehmen, weil der Patient viele verschiedene depressive Verstimmungen hat.
Die Verstimmungen leiden.
Und ich würde die Dosierung von L-Tiroxin vielleicht umsetzen.
Ich denke die Dosierung von L-Tiroxin ist nicht genug bei den Patienten.
Ja, und wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Ich empfehle den Patienten regelmäßig seinen Hausarzt zu besuchen, um die thyroid-schilderischen Werte zu kontrollieren.
Und auch eine Psychotherapie würde sinnvoll sein, weil der Patient viel Stress bei der Arbeit hat.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten Medikamente?
Als Medikamentostherapie würde ich L-Tiroxin anordnen.
Und der Patient leidet unter chronischer welinformiger Kopfschmerzen, Cephalgie.
Ich würde auch Ibuprofen anordnen gegen diese Schmerzen.
Und auch eine Kontrolle gegen Migräne empfehlen.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten operativ Behandlung?
Zuerst sollen wir eine Thyroidsynthographie durchführen, wenn wir eine kalte Knoten feststellen.
Dann können wir eine Fein-Nadelbiopsie durchführen.
Und wenn wir eine Katsynome feststellen, sollen wir eine Operation teilweise oder totale Thyrodectomie durchführen.
Warum der Patient Gewichtsabnehmen?
Der Patient leidet unter Appetitlosigkeit.
Dieses Symptom kann mit depressiver Verstimmung verbunden sein.
Oder eine Thyroid-Katsynome oder andere Katsynome können diese Gewichtsabnahme verursachen.
Wir sollen auf jeden Fall eine Katsynome überprüfen.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde eine Thyroidsynthographie durchführen.
Können Sie uns Thyroidsynthographie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über Thyroidsynthographie aufklären.
Thyroidsynthographie ist ein nuklearmidistinisches Verfahren.
Dieses Verfahren hilft uns, die Entzündungen und Tumore der Schilddrüse genauso zu erkennen.
Um diese Untersuchung zu machen, verabreichen wir den Patienten zuerst eine kleine Menge Nüblierstoffe.
Dann warten wir etwa 30 Minuten, als die Nüblierstoffe in die Schilddrüse gekommen sind.
Danach machen wir Bilder der Schilddrüse mit einer Gammakamera, um die kalten oder warmen Knoten zu beurteilen.
Nach der Untersuchung empfehlen wir den Patienten viel Wasser zu trinken, um die nuklearmidistinischen Stoffe, radioaktiven Stoffe, schneller auszuscheiden.
Es gibt nur wenige Komplikationen, wie zum Beispiel Wärme, Gefühl und es gibt einige Kontraindikationen, wie zum Beispiel Schwangerschaft.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde den Patienten radioaktive Stoffe geben. Welche radioaktive Stoffe geben Sie den Patienten?
Das war Comodium oder? Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich denke, radioaktive Stoffe geben immer troide Stoffe. Was erwarten Sie während der troide Sonographie?
Ja, bei der Untersuchung können wir Hypoecoik Schilddrüse feststellen.
Das ist eine Hypothriose und die häufigste Ursache von Hypothriose ist Hashimoto-Troide. Deswegen können wir eine kleine, verminderte Schilddrüse feststellen und auch eine hypoecoike Schilddrüse feststellen.
Was bedeutet Hypoecoik? Wir können eine verminderte Schilddrüse feststellen. Das ist die hypoecoike Schilddrüse.
Welche Knoten wissen Sie? Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, kalte Knoten und Wärme Knoten.
Es gibt ein großes Risiko für eine Katsinoma bei der kalten Knoten. Wärme Knoten bedeutet, die Durchblutung der Schilddrüse steigert.
Wie können wir Knoten-Type lernen?
Die Sintigraphie-Untersuchung hilft uns, um die Knoten genau zu erkennen. Die Dopplex-Sonographie zeigt mir nur die vermehrte Durchblutung.
Bei der Dopplex-Sonographie können wir keine kalten oder keine Wärme Knoten feststellen. Wir brauchen eine Sintigraphie, um die kalten oder Wärme Knoten zu beurteilen.
Können wir mit Hilfe der Sonographie eine retrosterne Quater oder eine vergrößerte Lymphknoten bewerten?
Wir können eine Röntgen des Torax durchführen, um die mögliche Vergrößerung der Schilddrüse durchzuführen.
Oder wir können eine oesophagische Ultrasonographie durchführen, um die vielleicht nicht vergrößert werden kann.
Wir können mit Hilfe der Troidsonographie eine retrosterne, vergrößerte Troidsdürse und vergrößerte Lymphknoten verwerten.
Aber machen wir einfach eine normale Troidsonographie?
Was beurteilen während der Troidsonographie?
Herr Kollegen, unsere Zeit ist um. Gehen Sie auf unseren Infodisc und nehmen Sie Ihre Self-Gate. Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihre Arbeitswege.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberst. Sie sind sehr nett. Das war eine sehr genehme Sprechzeit bei mir. Das war schwierig, aber schön. Danke.